John level password when Sky News
visited Jinjiang in September the power
of China's police state was clear these
were the visible signs of an intense
crackdown by Chinese authorities that
it's behind the walls of these detention
centers that crackdown is felt most the
Chinese government has sent more than a
million weakest a Muslim minority ethnic
group to centers like this for what it
calls voluntary job training US
officials have previously described them
as concentration camps and newly leaked
cables reinforced reports that they are
centers for forced ideological and
behavioral re-education what really
stood out from the document is that
right away the number one priority is to
prevent those quote-unquote students
from escaping the end game is to change
an entire minority population it's a
cultural genocide and it's a course of
social reengineering the documents came
from an anonymous source and the
international consortium of
investigative journalists verified them
by consulting experts cross-checking
content and comparing signatures they
described an elaborate scoring system
that grades detainees on how well they
speak Mandarin memorize ideology and
adhere to strict rules we had to talk to
a speaker to get permission to go to the
toilet and there were ten minutes of
toilet time each hour for all of us some
of us were able to go on this time in
some weren't we didn't waste water to
wash our hands we had two minutes to
shower with cold water each month they
would tell us that we were poisoned by
religion that Islam is an infectious
disease that it came from abroad that if
there needed to be a religion in China
that it must be Buddhism the papers also
show how Beijing is pioneering a new
form of social control using data and
artificial intelligence drawing on data
collected by mass surveillance
technology computers issued the names of
tens of thousands of people for
interrogation
or detention in just one week China has
denied the claims last week its
ambassador to the United Kingdom called
them fake news I'm telling you what you
the document so-called doctrine you're
talking about is a pure fabrications
don't listen to fake news
don't listen to fabrications a rare
comment from China on the detention
centers but as more details emerge of
what goes on here more questions will be
asked of the international community to
look closer
Kimberly Leonard sky news